salut à tous aujourd'hui on va parler de
apple apple qui s'apprête à sortir plein
de nouveaux produits très intéressants
en 2018 alors effectivement même si
apple a fait parler de lui dit façon
assez négative fin 2017 2018 devrait
quand même être une plutôt bonne année
pour un peu et ça justement on va en
parler
[Musique]
ces cochonneries sur l'objectif
là on nettoie ça alors apple s'apprête à
sortir plein de super produit il ya
plein de nouveaux talents comme d'hab
j'ai pris toutes mes jolies notes je
notais plein de choses
et justement on va en parler ensemble il
devrait y avoir cette année le fameux
ipod dont on a déjà parlé et qu'on
attend depuis quelques temps il devrait
y avoir trois nouveaux iphone
il devrait y avoir un ipad pro avec
faith heidi on aurait retrouvé également
le air power pour la recharge par
induction des nouveaux os une nouvelle
apple walsh des nouveau-nés repose enfin
énormément de choses alors on va
commencer par le home pod
[Musique]
le spot c'est l'enceinte connectés
intelligente d'apple on en a parlé déjà
il ya quelques mois
lorsqu'apple avait fait la présentation
faussée théodat bonne idée même s'ils
ont joué l'année dernière d'ailleurs je
vous ai mis un petit lien ici pour
retourner voir la vidéo de présentation
que vous avez fait sur ce produit là
c'est un produit qu'il veut sortir fin
2010 est en angleterre usa et australie
devait sortir normalement au mois de
décembre
il est reporté à début 2010 8 mais ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'en 2018 le mode
pourra équiper les foyers en tout cas
les foyers anglophone en france pour
l'instant pas de date de prévue
mais j'imagine que d'ici la fin de
l'année 2018 on pourrait retrouver sur
le marché son pote c'est très clairement
un concurrent d'amazon échos et de
google
aum c'est une enceinte connectés qui
servira pas uniquement à jouer de la
musique qui sera vraiment un assistant
pour votre maison et dès lors vous avez
un homme quitte avec des accessoires
connectée du philips you on peut
imaginer aussi des stores connectés
enfin énormément d'applications vous
pourrez piloter votre maison à la
reconnaissance vocale directement via
votre homme pod le mode très clairement
il a 7 twitter c'est pas le réseau
social avec le petit oiseau bleu on
parle vraiment des haut parleurs aiguë
il a un bouffeur pour les graves et il a
six micros
alors à quoi lui servent tous ces micro
alors effectivement capter votre voix
lorsque vous voulez par la syrie lui
pose une question demande et d'allumer
la lumière active est la télé ouvrir la
porte fermée leicester enfin passe un
coup de fil et tout ce genre de choses
là mais ça sert également aussi à
calibrer votre haut parleurs par rapport
à votre pièce c'est à dire que le son
qui va être émis du ipod dans toutes les
directions
peut-être réfléchie par les murs et ça
va le renvoyer ce sont va être captées
par les micros analysées par un mode
pour optimiser vraiment la puissance de
chaque haut-parleur par rapport à votre
pièce
ce qui fait que vous aurez un sont
homogènes et un son de meilleure qualité
vous savoir qu'à l'intérieur vous allez
avoir un processeur à 8 qui va
effectivement servir à tous calculs et à
toute l'intelligence des grands
guillemets que pourra vous offrir ces
appareils le seul inconvénient de la
musique c'est que vous serez limité
uniquement catalogue apple musique ça
vous savez de toute façon apple a plutôt
tendance à verrouiller
plutôt qu'à ouvrir mais bon dans
l'absolu ça peut être cadre relativement
intéressant de toute façon 2018 ça va
être aussi l'année de l'évolution et de
l'émergence de l'intelligence
artificielle
on va aller beaucoup plus loin beaucoup
plus loin dans la compréhension de vos
besoins et dans l'interaction vous allez
avoir avec les machines donc de toute
façon il faut bien s'attendre à ce que
les machines ont les pilotes avec la
voix qui est de moins en moins
d'appareils
alors ce mode sera positionné au milieu
de votre pièce pourquoi pas à plusieurs
dans votre maison
dès lors vous alignez parce que ça va
coûter quand même relativement cher
surtout si vous multipliez les appareils
mais l'idée effectivement c'est de
dématérialiser les appareils de plus
avoir à les piloter avec son avec ses
doigts mais le pilote est vraiment avec
la voix donc ça va être beaucoup plus
intéressant et c'est un endroit qu'on
pourra retrouver au tarif de 349 dollars
d'ailleurs dit moi vous ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
un pote peut-être quelque chose de bien
est ce que c'est une solution
intéressante
est ce que c'est une solution d'avenir
et vous mettez tout ça en commentaire et
en discutent ensemble
autre nouveauté chez apple pour cette
année 2010 8 c'est l'arrivée probable de
trois nouveaux iphone alors vous
attendez plus du tout avoir et iphone
ancienne génération avec un design
classique comme tous les appareils qu'on
a connu jusqu'au 1/8 plus ça normalement
ça devrait être terminé fini on va se
retrouver avec des looks comme l'iphone
10 avec des grands écrans avec ou sans
encoches normalement a priori on peut
regarder à gauche encore un petit moment
et trois nouveaux appareils justement
pour cette nouvelle année
le premier à peu près le même look que
ce qu'on trouve sur l'iphone 10,1
d'écran 5,8 pouces oled avec une caméra
trou d'eps le même aspect les mêmes
dimensions
le deuxième aura un écran plus grand ça
sera un iphone 10 plus avec un écran de
6,5 pouces on gardera également un écran
oled et vont 3 est bon d'avoir un écran
de 6,1 pouces cette fois ci en lcd
pourquoi tout simplement pour avoir un
appareil moins cher
un iphone je dirais pas d'entrée de
gamme parce que ça serait faux pas de
milieu de gamme
ce serait faux mais un peu moins cher
que le prix de l'iphone dit il faut
s'attendre à ce que ses prises cette
année baisse légèrement on devrait se
retrouver avec les premiers iphone 10 en
dessous des 1000
trop peut-être 900 peut-être 850 euros
pour l'iphone de 2017
l'iphone x de 2018 pourrait pourquoi pas
se positionner le tout premier en tout
cas aux alentours des 950 euros en
dessous des 1000 euros et après le dise
plus on peut imaginer retrouver
effectivement à 1300 euros
on va toujours gardé ce design bord à
bord on aura toujours
saï saï dit toujours la caméra trop
d'aix il y aura plus de chalets dit plus
de bouton home sachant que de toute
façon ce que je suis complètement
entériné chez apple on peut aussi
imaginer que le modèle avec l'écran 6,1
pouces en cd puisse appeler le est ce
numéro 2 pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
effectivement le lui donner cette
dénomination ça paraît pas complètement
déconnant alors après le nom de l'iphone
est-ce qu'ils vont garder la
dénomination disent allez sur le onze
bon le rose n'y crois pas trop
le 10 versions 2 prend pas trop non plus
iphone progrès tout simplement dire qu'à
partir de maintenant ce sont les iphone
c'est l'iphone de 2018 ou alors comme
ils font sur leur os on peut très bien
imaginer l iphone sierra l'iphone ait si
rahal iphone jaguar panthère ou que ça
j'ai encore pourquoi pas d'ailleurs
dites moi ce que vous en pensez à votre
avis comment est ce que apple vont
appeler leurs nouveaux appareils
maintenant de toute façon ne voit très
bien que la dénomination l'iphone 8 7 6
9 s'est un petit peu mort donc on va se
trouver carrément autre chose donc vous
mettez tout sans commentaire et puis
comme ça je suis curieux de faire un
petit peu faire un peu le sondage
ils garderont également un dos en verre
pour la recharge par induction des
caméras toujours plus performantes des
appareils toujours plus puissants on
peut imaginer arriver de la puce à 12
pour aller plus loin dans le calcul
au niveau de la réalité augmentée que de
meilleures batteries d'ailleurs les
batteries c'est un petit peu le le point
négatif de cette fin d'année 2010 est
pour apple voilà un peu ce qu'on sait
tout de suite pour ces trois nouveaux
iphone qui devrait arriver en 2018 à
partir du mois de septembre
bien évidemment il devrait y avoir
également en 2018 un nouvel ipad pro un
nouvel ehpad pro avec un design repensé
grand écran on sait pas si on aura du
oled ou du lcd
peut-être que apple pour l'ipad gardera
du lcd bon à mon avis le oled
on va y aller à moi notre est ce que ce
sera en 2018 ou en 2019 pour l'ipad
enfin pour l'ipad seront en tout cas ça
pour l'instant on ne sait pas pourquoi
pas en tout cas le le web ça pourrait
être
vraiment vraiment super beau sur un ipad
pro en imaginant c'est grand écran ça
pourrait être carrément déchiré de toute
façon le bouton home pareil sur l'ipad
pro va disparaître on trouvera une
caméra trou d'aix pour notre façon d
groovy avec faye side il faut imaginer
d'une manière générale el sayed hisser
la techno d'apple pour déverrouiller
donc tout ce qui est des verrouillages
par empreinte digitale
ça va disparaître devra forcément un
processeur plus rapide une machine
capable d'aller plus loin en terme de
calcul notamment pour la réalité
augmentée parce que l'ipad pro un vrai
usage pour les professionnels et la
réalité augmentée sert énormément au
niveau des professionnels on va pouvoir
aller plus loin au niveau de la
conceptualisation et au niveau de la de
la création produit donc il faut de la
capacité de calcul derrière donc il faut
un processeur plus rapide et ça
forcément apple va taper dessus on va
regarder sensiblement les mêmes ratios
d'écran 10 5 pouces et le 12,9 pouces
qu'on a cette année alors il faut savoir
que on devrait pouvoir retrouver un ipad
un peu low cost jeu tournée des grandes
villes mais quand je dis aux crises avec
apple en 2018 peut-être en écran lcd
probablement pas de l'oled mais un ipad
châtiment qui serait toujours un peu
moins cher avec la caméra trou d'aix est
bien évidemment plus de boutons rhône
il devrait y avoir du nouveau du côté de
l'apple watch il devrait y avoir la
série 4 qui va arriver
alors il faut savoir qu'avec depuis le
lancement les apple watch il n'y a pas
eu de vrai travail de recréation au
niveau du design en garde les mêmes
design alors sondé design qui fonctionne
qui ont été prouvés qu'ils plaisent mais
pour cette édition quatre de la watch on
pourrait imaginer avoir un design un
petit peu retravaillé et avoir quelque
chose d'un peu différent
avoir un écran avec un peu plus de
couleurs un peu plus des limites de
luminosité des choses un petit peu plus
punchy
il doit aussi y avoir des capteurs plus
performants pour aller toujours plus
loin dans la santé connecter toute façon
la médecine prédictive ça l'a vraiment
être la médecine de l'avenir tous ces
capteurs vous avez là vont permettre de
connaître vos problèmes vos besoins de
santé avant même que vous ayez déclaré
maladie et ça c'est vraiment pertinent
est super intéressant alors le
problème qu'on rencontre sur ces sur ses
ouailles si vous voulez c'est que si
vous serrez pas trop bracelet vous avez
quand même un peu de jeu et le capteur
est pas forcément super bien en place
après ces bracelets en plastique lorsque
vous laissez rétro et vous êtes un homme
ça vous arracher les poils alors si vous
êtes une femme et que ça vous arrache
les poils de l'avant-bras peut-être
avez-vous une pilosité un petit peu trop
développé aller visiter un essai titien
ou une esthéticienne pour ça après les
régionales mais bon c'est pas la chute
c'est pas la question du jour tout ça
pour dire qu'on va avoir une once
normalement édition numéro 4 qui
arriverait au mois de septembre on si
côté nouveautés on devrait avoir le air
power qui vous permettra de recharger
votre world series 3 de charger vos
airpod et votre iphone 10 directement
sur la même base
on sait qui va arriver en 2018 c'est une
annonce officielle d'apple
on ne connaît pour l'instant pas le prix
mais on connaît apple donc on imagine
que ça sera pas cadeau cadeaux autre
nouveauté on devrait avoir des repos des
nouveaux horaires potes qui devrait
arriver cette année alors l'air quand
vous les connaissez probablement ce sont
les petits écouteurs son fil en
bluetooth de apple
très discrète et sympa qui se met ici
bon j'ai pas encore eu l'opportunité
d'essayer mais ça ne saurait tarder mais
c'est repos devraient être retravaillé
en débit 18 meilleures connexions
bluetooth nouveau design et surtout des
couleurs ces petits haut parleurs blanc
c'est mignon c'est discret mais bon on
verra tout un petit peu de choses un peu
plus tonique un peu plus punchy
on peut imaginer du rose à ségur à lyon
on peut imaginer des bleus d'autres
teintes dont ça ça devrait vraiment
quelque chose de très sympa épicé airpod
de toute façon c'est vraiment c'est un
produit qui va se démocratiser
alors les hauts parleurs en bluetooth je
trouve ça bien je suis pas super super
convaincu chastain un grand fan du port
jack mais bon pourquoi pas en quoi ça va
dans le bon sens vraiment aussi d'autres
nouveautés côté des imac un imac qui
devrait arriver avec plus de
performances un imac revisité avec un
meilleur processeur les macbook pro ci
devraient être revus heures tous les ans
les macbook pro on leur en rajoute un
petit peu pour que on est un modèle un
peu plus sympa il ya la touch barque et
qui est sympa bon ça fait un peu gadget
des fois on peut aussi trouver certaines
applications intéressantes pourquoi pas
sur la touch bart weyn aux sur les
applications de montage ça peut avoir un
sens donc ce nouveau macbook pro 2018
devrait avoir forcément plus de ram un
ssd encore plus performant plus de
qualité de stockage meilleures capacités
de calcul plus bel écran donc voilà donc
ça on en reparlera bien
avant cette année les macbook pourrait
également être revisitée et les os
devrait aussi être revue tous les ans il
ya des mises à jours qui arrivent
eyeos 12 devrait arriver on devrait
avoir mac os 10 points 14
walsh os 5 tvos 12
alors tout ça doit être annoncée
normalement d'abbottabad où elle si en
juin 2018
donc restez connectés ça je vous en
reparlerai parce que tout au long de
l'année
dès qu'il y aura des annonces des
rumeurs vraiment intéressante qui nous
permettront d'aller plus loin sur la
compréhension des futurs projets et des
futurs produits d'apple
on en reparlera dès que les produits
seront annoncés on en parlera gelé
testerait donc rester connecté parce que
vers plein plein plein d'infos sur tous
les nouveaux produits apple
on parle effectivement de tout ce qui va
sortir cette année chez apple mais il
faut aussi parler de ce qui ne sortira
pas parce qu'à des attentes et des
choses qui à priori ne devrait pas voir
le jour
alors chez a pas cette année on ne
devrait toujours pas avoir de lunettes
de réalité virtuelle a priori peut-être
en 2020 ça avance doucement
pour l'instant la réalité virtuelle ne
fait pas partie des projets prioritaires
chez apple
si jamais il y à des rumeurs dans ce
sens en 2018 bien évidemment je vous en
parlerai ce qui ne devrait pas non plus
arriver tout de suite tout de suite chez
apple ce sont les écrans pliables
d'ailleurs j'ai fait une vidéo des
écrans pliables vous en parlait ici
normalement c'est pareil les écrans
pliables chez apple devait retrouver
normalement en 2020 soyez pas trop
pressé mais toutes ces choses-là
arriveront dans les années à venir
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
dites moi en commentaire tout ce que
vous en pensez de ces nouveaux produits
est ce que ces trois nouveaux iphone
pourrait vous intéresser est ce que les
nouveaux rires crottes de couleur
pourrez vous tentez le mode parce que
c'est un produit qu un sens oui ou non
est ce que vous auriez besoin d'un
nouveau macbook pro postale et enfin
vous mettez tout sans commentaire on
discute ensemble
je remercie beaucoup d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo vous avez un essai des
jolies pousse bien sûr à vous abonner il
à rester connectés parce qu'on prendra
toujours toujours toujours plus de high
tech plus toujours mieux et quant à moi
je vous dis à bientôt partez vous bien
et ce paysage ciao